I'd love to hear a guest's top three
revenue streams I operate and invest
right now I'm the CEO of a company
called Vayner X Vayner media is the big
company in that my company does the
marketing for companies like Pepsi and
Chase we killed Mr Peanut oh wow we were
the agency that worked on Planters when
we killed Mr P during the Super it's an
ad agency but it's 2024 version almost
every client we work with we're like do
you understand how important it is to do
social media liquid death yeah started
by Mike the job he had while he was
building liquid death was at Vayner
media in La wow sent me an email like
I'm ready to do my own thing do you want
to invest I'm like yeah I wanted to
support him he's a good dude I was like
here's a couple bucks I'm going to make
a fortune on it cuz he's a beast and he
built liquid death Mike cesio is a very
very impressive guy the CEO of liquid
death that's right I do a lot of
investing so obviously one day liquid
death will sell to Pepsi or Coke and
I'll get a check for that investment
yeah how soon do you think that's going
to
happen are you an invest